how the game resumes periodic paths
welcome back to corpse party a.m. last
chapter was so breathtakingly awesome I
am so excited for chapter 2 we are gonna
do this so let's continue I suppose yeah
chapter 2 opening yes I have not seen
that so Oh God Jesus
she doesn't have to hold them up like
that I guess she forgot to wear her bra
so we got a bit of backstory here which
is kind of weird is pomf Mel Horace what
the hell is that it's one of those is
she looking at her ass again like this
is how girls talk you just talk about
how cute your butt sorry I'm learning so
much from these games plump like a
that's hot yes childbearing hips
what that sounds pervert is that good
and she's blushing too but well with
those tits you can feed a [ __ ] town
[Music]
smothered Lee quality new okay you
should really so what I call don't want
your new LSU kana poor children death
sound like you oh like it what what
Oh God oh god no don't take me back here
I don't want to be here I don't want to
experience that [ __ ] again let's hire a
ball so here goes
Chapter two breasts it should be a good
one we get a little intro dance
so is this how the teacher cool love the
music in this game I'm really glad it
got it to work it wasn't working when I
try to emulate this long time ago so
it's nice to me then
[Music]
why she's so scared of Alejandra tea
she's like shut the [ __ ] up please
[Music]
how does that work
yeah probably that yes of course
[Music]
okay okay sir take off all a meteor ooh
ah this is a mother day Donna you poke
around over there Jimmy that's cocoa
Nina
tell me oh god stop
[Music]
okay we're going leaving these [ __ ]
how does she walking those high heels
then okay that sounds like a good time
[Music]
she's such a good teacher valor that
name is education yeah let's do it
the we places here or was that there I
wonder if like any effect like that well
no this is near let's take it it's a key
three A's take it gasps of course all
right we got the key what does this say
no teacher is allowed on the third floor
thanks well too bad so the other guy can
go like what's that don't diddly diddly
three a let's find it return home
immediately those who remain here will
go hungry and die of starvation
wonderful
oh are you thinking about her kitty that
should be as a spin-off series from this
game with our kitty trying to find food
or something oh so this is two-way that
means three I shouldn't be too far away
let's just check everything to be safe
[Music]
over the past month numerous children
have a gun missing so we've been in here
before
oh [ __ ] flam what is that the door open
that doesn't really help us that much we
could have just walked so this must be
3a yep let's go ingress I have a bad
feeling about this
what meaneth why why is she talking to
him so confidently how much less there
is in Japanese never ever really I don't
believe so maybe we'll find dead bodies
and they the evil spirits
oh we know we know I know anyone are you
god damn it what are the pessimists
antoshka kodachi sake cocoon it's ready
Kurata you lucky dog Coco diva dick
emoji game Oh Barbara dot sake oh shoot
oh so this is a different spirit from
the other bliss brain yeah
non-gmo mine yeah I got the he may not
okay many is no that'd be cool Eric
[Music]
hates nine call it a Jewish again oh it
is okay doctor hey step aside doctor you
doctor [ __ ] all right so we got a
cabinet and they will tell us all this
stuff okay oh [ __ ]
oh no it's an evil spirit Oh an
earthquake
what the [ __ ] oh
Oh God looking at one okay I care what's
gonna happen here I don't think oh [ __ ]
yeah like how would they live forever in
the holes if they don't eat or whatever
season otherone die got trapped in there
come on come in and save her already or
you don't call me a [ __ ] [ __ ] Oh God
don't die that's an attack laughs I knew
that actually why that's impossible
Sugie Sugie are you
what kill the hell it can it will flame
do anyway oh no oh dad
that's gotta suck Freddie Mac dead frog
on the what no no did I [ __ ] up what
meanwhile Oh God
they heard the earthquake
[Music]
now she's fine she's a bad feeling -
chefs exactly not do something oh yeah
Jesus meets gotta back up tada
sougamoto - koukin ah all right that
makes sense
chase okay okay I promise we're going
[Music]
silver key my Nana Camuto
that's against doing a jaw jaw pokin
eatable coca
[Music]
I'm pretty sure they could write
anywhere
look I need meat Allah Cordina way to be
yeah bang my you've got a battle day
home oh god okay
I bet she's gonna cry like a [ __ ] and
I'm gonna be like oh oh oh my god so
they won't find out about her because
this is room classroom to a yeah it is
well the same thing happened if we read
this the Dory is affixed when if we read
this now oh hello
and trigger something it's cold in here
the own made a whole new babe sword
Anika dr. Corrina she does like you huh
give her give her the jacket sake Qaeda
on AutoKey need scuttle or suka or that
all hey there was a candle in here so
let's get a joke like yeah suppose i
disgust you are doc I don't know so
that's why I was in there interesting
[Music]
sorry if I could cut too early Anna
I would be freaking out if that happened
- actually I don't want to talk [ __ ]
so the earthquake is there as we can't
move any farther really it seems like oh
yeah
teacher we're in ilaria yeah now we can
go awesome
god damn th you dead lady Neji
alright let's read this if you acquire
any name tags from the corpses in this
school please bring them to me I'll add
them to my collection custodian what the
[ __ ] what's that hey let's do it again
ouch [ __ ] what for smiling children I've
surrounded an adult and merrily stabbing
him to death they're all so happy about
it yet how unsettling what they would do
it what god damn it that's this game's
so [ __ ] up alright let's do what I
intended in the beginning and just
[ __ ] walk south and we'll see what
happens
alright what do we get oh god I don't
like the sound of this oh this is an
acetylene [ __ ] man
alright let's read this many friends who
are able to retain their sanity and
reason will be your final ray of hope
thank you very much kind Lee osho's I
love shoes fantastic
I'll great marshes we're in the
entranceway what the hell is that even
mean
you can cross on these I don't like this
and chance that we can't exit right the
front entranceway might as well be
painted on it's neither
opening nor giving any hints that it
will ever open while they made a noise I
think that's not him did I forget to
read something sorry one second
sometimes it triggers [ __ ] you never
know each time you turn around stop for
a moment and ask yourself it's the world
behind you back still there thank you
note for your deep philosophies now but
I get the earthquakes keep changing
things here it seems like a wonderful
bunch of oh the difference is
fingerlings and bites or me you doc I'm
learning Japanese here Cheers
Jesus for a you me
for a horror expert she really doesn't
oh god oh yeah oh yeah walk over I
[Music]
really hope [ __ ]
ah I wonder who's gonna die I feel like
every alright
[Music]
judging by the sides these appear to be
remains of a junior or senior high
school student and we got an ID nametag
kya Shimada kaki zombie do they all have
name tags this one is two more here or
okay I have weird names of Japan man
that's all I have to say about that oh
oh oh oh this doesn't look good at all
victim memoirs 1 out of 5 I ate my
friend today that's a good tweet right
there what else was I supposed to do I
was starving
we both were and there's no food here so
we decided together that one of us
should try to live just a little bit
longer if I ever get home I I'm supposed
to tell all the people waiting for us
what happened we left it all up to a
game of paper scissors Rock loser eats
winner Wow nice and I lost I felt her
blood going down my throat quenching my
thirst and her meat was supple and
satisfying what death [ __ ]
but that blood and that meat was once my
friend up until just a few hours before
I'd been talking about the hairy as I
feasted I just kept thinking this food
used to be a person before I tore it
apart it all worked together to sustain
a life and every time I thought about
that I started crying and I couldn't
stop I wanted some part of her to be
with me even after she died so I decided
to keep one of her eye
molls and i thought maybe i should write
all this down to help preserve some
small portion of my sanity
Jesus [ __ ] up there's a decaying
skeleton remains here about the size of
a middle school student they're in the
process of slowly drying in with her in
creating an almost overpowering stench
throughout the hallway any clothing the
deceased had been wearing it's long gone
so there's no means of really least
identifying gender on-site well we know
it's a girl that's [ __ ] up man [ __ ]
[ __ ] up man oh god what is this yeah
what the [ __ ] no no come on
in Moscow boy dies okay ah well let's go
I don't have a problem with that an hour
okay let's go it's fine come on let's go
okay no God oh yeah we're staying then
oh she's just like however bad oh god oh
god it's gonna fall isn't it oh god oh
god oh god oh god oh god I did no good
what how does she know all this okay I'm
done looking into his eyes a rusted
blood-soaked blood-soaked
nail puller is oh god yeah I mean we
could always use a nail puller
god I love char lob nail pullers what
the [ __ ] is that though okay you know
what let's just try this [ __ ]
oh nothing
[Music]
Oh getting buried alive
all right don't do this stupid [ __ ] like
that good thing I think I know some elk
[ __ ] no there you go [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you don't let it
okay well let's trust her from that one
let's trust her okay great great times
great idea all right we got something
we got a nail puller [ __ ] that man
what's in here is this the principal
again
I can't even click on it that's weird
right we have a nail puller now so how
we found a name tag Emiko doy alright
cool did we go here before I don't think
so
can't be open Oh God I don't like that
sound shut up the word you don't fart in
front of me another note and another
dead body
there's the hasting we've written note
on the ground its writers seem to have
struggle with it as the lettering is an
inconsistent and difficult to read why
sister it hurts it hurts after I'd died
the pain will after I die with a favor
will continue forever no no no no no no
no oh
I will never forgive you no [ __ ]
[ __ ] that [ __ ] god damn it there's an
erratic noise like that of a TV static
coming from within Oh God
all right you know what let's just say
we came from here right I don't know
breaths I'm a little lost right now it's
a lot of dead bodies and safe uh-oh what
is she doing she being she has to poop
probably oh that's a lovely sound that's
my new ringtone
well they have to poop come on hurry up
follow her what the [ __ ] was that all
about that was creepy as [ __ ] I wonder
where she went though probably back up
to the classroom right oh [ __ ] there she
is
[Applause]
what okay it's
shinozaki boy boy Oh what the [ __ ]
um no go my hand a little so it does all
mm-hmm don't me you knew exactly what
you were doing put it on Mars this
chinchilla white dinner huh yeah key all
think I'm all what do you know hey
Jeanie Boulet
well he's an ER sweetie pie Jesus
Japanese people seems to have a lot of
like empathy oh [ __ ] we walk right into
that [ __ ] oh no oh no it's that the boy
[Music]
know what if we go back in [ __ ] that oh
there we go
all right touchy but I thought blue
spreads for okay oh god he's coming
isn't he mother of [ __ ] what am I
supposed to do what my mane oh thank god
oh god oh god I'm going I'm going [ __ ]
you bows closed bows whatever the you
are oh [ __ ] oh god okay okay okay oh
candle yes candle [ __ ] yeah yeah all
right let's keep going
I like this music more let's go back and
check in the hole cuz maybe teachers
back we don't know that she's not back
but we know that they don't know that so
I figured that it would be the thing to
do maybe they will I saw it with some
sort of that louder than something I
I wouldn't have have hmmm have have gone
untouched looks like she hasn't come
back yet you mean you don't know
and there is nailed shut all that kind
of name you just use a hammer to do that
yeah of course
[ __ ] yet my god I'm dumb I don't even
know although successfully is losing
every nail in the door the rusted old
nail puller broke apart in the process
well that's is still a win I'd say
there's a high fiber the there's a piece
of scrap paper pinned onto the wall you
know this dark spots on the page I
realize sir tear stains those who choose
to ignore the darkness that dwells in
the hearts of men may be stuck forever
in a loop for in this world there are
some truth that simply must be known no
matter how disturbing but curiosity can
be deadly
you know the truth our best left untold
we were the messages of the dead for
they for there be curses among them
curses that company can crush even the
strongest winds demolishing all
semblance of reason if you wish to
protect your sanity take heed do not let
your curiosity get the better of you do
not read victim's memoir to their
conclusion we're back here now whatever
it is face thing a control mechanism for
some sort of elaborate pulley system or
a space thing as that's better
explanation ripped off with a network of
find virtually transferred threads
there's a lever jutting out from one
side I don't see what else we will do
probably should've safe oh it's like one
of those so that one's starting now what
how did we know that did we like or just
we know that that is making a scent hey
cherry alright the boys still here which
is bad news for us
Oh boys yeah I'm looking at you bit okay
okay okay I guess we have to lure him
down here that's pretty good
Oh God oh [ __ ] come on that's how we do
it ten a-m you [ __ ] you've stuck there
forever okay we need to go up here I
think I do quite frankly hi Skelly's how
you doing good snips are growing as a
matter of this we speak I think I don't
[ __ ] I don't remember where it was
was it in here the word classroom is it
here it's loading yes yes it is here
okay let's just hope he doesn't attack
us from behind it's never good to be
attacked from behind it appears to be a
control mechanism from suicidal
Abaddon's we knew this yes yes and that
opens what exactly a bridge by the shoes
a shoe branch yes let's go oh [ __ ] oh
god funky music
what do you do in this [ __ ] music no
no no oh [ __ ] what's it about to happen
how the [ __ ] are we gonna do this oh god
oh god ah
what you gonna do a bad night what you
gonna do about that huh
what you gonna do about don't follow me
please don't you [ __ ] follow me
because I'm lost [ __ ] [ __ ] that's what I
had not wanted him to do
[ __ ] I say Oh God alright the Shoebridge
the shoe branch where is it there just
found it
alright the curse writings left behind
by those who lost all the weights and
misread properly order if you insist in
reading such anyway yeah pretty strong
historian [ __ ] thank you alright that oh
okay okay KKK we have a brush another
branch thank you
thank you very much it seems like you
can fail a lot more in this one oh [ __ ]
don't be scared in Ozaukee now show your
Moyer
oh you mean that's
[Music]
hey you know what you want damn candle
Oh fantastic gonna have to end this
episode here breaths hope you enjoyed
watching and a lot of fun playing so go
ahead and leave a like it will help me
analyze and leave a comment of how you
think the candles will feel if you smell
them
what flavored candles there are it's a
surprise like you back